Oh my god, condense!
Condense!
Condense, my convert!
Moshiwake, our masein.
We were...
Mwake, our mwakein.
Just a little bit late.
Yes, so, so sorry.
Sorry.
It's okay.
Why am I saying it's okay to us?
We don't deserve to be forgiven, Phoebe.
Welcome you guys to DenSetsu.exe's six month anniversary
celebration.
Please do let us know if the sound balance is okay.
I'm doing my best visually right now.
But I can adjust.
I can adjust both volume and our individual.
voices.
Wow, thank you to all of our Denchi for all the love and
support over the past six months.
Not or seven, it's just six.
Oh yeah, Phoebe, it's just seven.
It's not just six?
In between right now.
Why would we add a month?
When Phoebe says no, you know, you know you've taken it too
far, Chad.
It will be seven next month.
We have missed our six-month anniversary by a week, so we
are in the middle of six...
And you know what, let's just stop.
Let's just stop here.
We're gonna stop here.
Yeah, let's just... I'll find... Let's just leave it there.
How about that?
Yeah.
Yes.
But thanks so much for joining us today on this special,
special day.
How are you guys feeling, Minto and Vicky?
Six months together.
Oh, so happy.
Yeah.
So happy.
Happy, happy, happy.
Happy, happy.
But no, like, I don't know, we've achieved so much in these
short six months already.
There's so many exciting things on the horizon.
Yeah.
And I know it's just the first six months of a long, lovely
time with you both.
And I just want to celebrate with everybody here.
So, yeah.
It feels like way longer than six months.
I don't know why like just feels like I don't know like well
technically we've been in it together well we've been we've
been in the Gulags together for the we've been in the
trenches together since like over a year now like a year and
a half now yeah yeah that's true maybe I guess that's why
yeah there was so much planning that happened behind the
scenes and then I don't know Every week and we talked and we
hung out and...
It somehow feels like even longer than that too though.
It feels like you guys are like my sisters, you know?
Yeah, I feel the same way.
I feel so blessed to have two very wonderful sisters.
Yeah.
Aww, it's so sweet.
Aww.
So nice.
Right?
It's been a wonderful time.
We've been on so many adventures and there's so much more
we're gonna be doing.
So many more things to show Phoebe!
I know!
Food!
I feel like so, I feel so baby when it comes to a lot of
things.
And Mint and Vicky are always showing me new.
They can show me the world.
They show me the world.
They do.
Mouth of granote shine and shit.
Sorry for the muggy, Tim.
Granola.
Wait, what are you eating?
Is it with yogurt and fruit by any chance?
It is!
I've been called out!
It's our favorite, our favorite breakfast.
It's so good, though.
It is, isn't it?
It's so good.
I'm glad you love it.
I need it with my Roy-Bos tea.
Oh yeah, Roy-Bos tea!
Yes, in the palace cat mug.
Love that Roy-Bos.
Yes, aww, you got aww.
I'm bad you guys getting so used to my place.
I mean, I guess the old collabs do end up being there a lot.
Yeah.
It's like another home at this point, honestly.
Aww, that is very sweet.
I know the route to your...
To your... to your...
our kid, Vicky, the steps you take.
Aw, thank you guys.
Appreciate it.
Oh, I mean, Minto maybe didn't appreciate some parts of it
so much, like my keyboard, but...
What was wrong with the keyboard?
I still have that picture for Blackmail.
No!
Was it not foggy enough?
What was wrong with it?
Oh, no.
You used it, you used it, Phoebe.
I did use it.
You saw the slide, right?
Wait, you didn't notice, Phoebe?
You didn't notice...
The fuzz?
Well, it's typically like...
Spuzz!
You know how like 70s bathrooms used to have like, uh...
Like...
Like carpet in the bathroom?
That's what it reminded me of.
Ew!
What?
It's not that bad!
You didn't even notice!
It's ridiculous.
I didn't notice, but to be fair, like a lot of the streams
I'd do at your house were at like 7 in the morning or
something, so I'd roll out of bed and be like, Time to
stream!
And then I went...
I didn't notice the fuzzy keyboard!
I didn't notice!
Oh my god!
I noticed the fuzzy keyboard!
Now I'm not gonna be able to unnotice it next time I'm
there.
Thank you.
No, she'll clean it, right?
I believe in you.
Oh?
Oh, will you?
Sure, sure.
Yeah, I'll clean it.
Yeah, sure.
Sure, I'll clean it.
Well, what if she's attached to it?
How'd she even clean it?
I don't understand.
What if it's her comfort fuzz?
Yeah, Minto, yeah!
Who am I to judge?
Do you snack at your desk too?
Um, well I'm eating breakfast on my desk right now.
Alright, fine.
That's what I'll do.
My first thing after the six month anniversary I'll clean my
keyboard, okay chat?
You happy?
Guys, if, um, if on the very special thing that's gonna be
premiering after this if on that we get if we get at least
If we get more views on that video than we did on Densetsu
MVPs, Vicky will clean the fuzz off her keyboard.
Yeah!
Good idea, Phoebe.
Good idea.
Incentivize the fuzz cleaning.
Hand cam idea.
Hand cam clean the keyboard.
If we get more views on Densetsu MVPs.
Then there will be a hand cam fuzz cleaning stream.
Woohoo!
Should I pull out my ASMR mic and bring it to you so you can
ASMR keyboard fuzz clean?
Is that a thing that people would want?
I suppose it would actually sound quite nice like the little
I don't know what you use to clean them like little pipe
cleaners She doesn't even know what to use to clean the
keyboard Pipe cleaners I mean you could use pipe cleaners
You could You could There are other tools but yeah you could
cleaner, I suppose.
Yeah.
Those are all so fuzzy.
All right.
Well, fine.
So I've got, I've, I'll clean my keyboard.
What are you guys going to do if we get more views and
denser-turfing views?
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Cool.
Help you clean your keyboard?
I don't know.
Well, a group off.
It's a two-man job.
Everyone cleans it.
Okay, while we're at it, can we build the exercise bike I
haven't built for two years as well at the same time?
Oh, yeah.
We will clean Vicky's keyboard.
We will build her exercise bike.
We will...
I don't know, uh, ASMR bathroom cleaning or something.
I'm not sure.
Excellent.
This sounds like a reproductive stream.
We're just cleaning up Vicky's house.
Excellent.
Sounds great.
It says Minto's gotta do a reading of Minotaur milking.
What is that?
Wait, oh.
How can I do a reading?
Wait, who said this?
Nobody said.
Someone in chat.
That doesn't exist.
Okay, that was just, I just kind of made that up in my head.
There was no comment about Minotaur Milky.
Somebody projected that idea into your brain.
Yeah, they beamed it into my mind.
How dare you?
How dare, get out of my head!
Get out of my head!
They found the power to get inside people's brains and
they're using it to beam Phoebe out of Minotaur Milky.
Okay.
I'm not even thinking you could use that powerful.
I'm a morning glory milking farm.
Okay, Chad, please.
Morning glory?
Milk?
You can milk a morning glory.
Oh, Chad is frozen.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Are they okay?
What?
Hmm.
Let me just try to refresh that.
Will that help?
Get out the freezer, Chad.
Oh, there.
There we go.
Okay.
Let me know when that happens.
and I'll refresh it.
Um...
But yeah!
Uh, today...
Well, as you guys heard earlier, um, at the very end of the
stream, at...
In about...
Two hours...
I think?
Yeah, two hours...
At, uh...
6.30 p.m.
Pacific...
9.30 p.m.
Eastern.
What is that for you, Vicky?
I don't know.
Uh...
No idea.
I'll just roll with it.
10.30 a.m.
JST.
630 PST.
We will be having a special premiere so that we're going to
raid into.
Ooh.
And if that premiere gets that many views, then keyword
cleaning.
But there's...
There's going to be some other stuff.
There's going to be others to be...
We haven't thought about this yet, but there will be other
stuff.
But I think the video in and of itself is a reward enough,
to be honest.
I agree.
What are your guys'...
Without spoiling too much.
Wait, we kind of gave our one word or one phrase impressions
of the video on our podcast for Patreons recently.
But is there anything else you'd like to say?
Actually, we like literally just got to watch the completed
video right before this.
It might have been why we were late.
So, oopsie.
That was definitely while I was late.
I watched it so much.
I know, me too.
I was just grinning the whole time.
It was, it was, yeah, we clutched this so hard, but it was
with the help is because of an amazing, amazing team that it
was able to even get done in time for today.
So thank you everybody.
Thank you.
But what are you guys' impressions now?
Having watched the, yeah, impressions.
Impressions of the secret video?
Yes.
Without spoiling the contents of the secret video?
Okay, let me think about this.
That's so hard.
It's very secret.
That's my impression.
It is very, very secret.
I think you never know what's gonna come next.
Okay, that is very true, yeah.
Actually, that's a good way of putting it.
I think it'll keep you on your toes the entire time.
You're gonna be like, what is even...
You'll be like, oh, wow, this is crazy.
And then something else will happen completely.
like take a take a hard left turn and you'll be like what
the heck okay what's gonna happen now and then I'll take
another hard left turn and you'll be like uh yeah but and we
we are very much teasing it so you will have to stick around
for two more hours and two hours it will be it will be
premiered I sent something in the chat that maybe we could
reveal that could get people excited oh oh maybe I don't
know do you think that's an okay thing to reveal I like so?
We can keep that a secret still.
Oh, I think that's fine.
Then they can, people that were part of it can get excited.
Yeah.
I like the way we're all like huddled together.
We're like, yeah.
Secrets.
Hey, you listening in on us?
You're listening in?
Hey.
No boys allowed.
But girls didn't.
and anything in between.
Come here.
Yeah, girl density, come here.
Anyway, guys, yeah, the video, some of you, members of the
Patreon, might have recorded something a little while back,
perhaps.
I would say that if you recorded something as part of the
Patreon, that you should be...
Very excited, wouldn't you say guys?
I'd say so.
Very excited.
Why was everyone's reaction?
Oh god, I forgot rather than yay.
Beef sighting!
Beef sight?
What do you mean you forgot?
Was that not the most important thing you've ever recorded
in your entire life?
How did you forget?
Jeez.
But yeah, very, very exciting stuff.
What else can you say?
Yeah, you never know what's coming.
It's so hard.
I could only say the stuff I said last time.
I think it's also very us.
That means anything.
It's so us.
It reeks of Den setsu.
It reeks of weird little guy.
We all contributed our own little weird ideas.
We did.
It's...
The sad thing about having to read into it is that we won't
immediately be able to talk about like everything we want to
talk about about it but surely surely in the coming like
days and weeks we will definitely yap about it.
We should do a stream sometime to talk about it probably.
We sure we have so many stories.
So many.
I feel so bad because I feel like the past couple of trips
it's been like oh I can't really talk about what we're
doing.
I mean, I did stuff with Densetsu.
Boop.
Yeah.
Now you guys will know what we were doing.
Though, to be honest, it was only one of several things that
we've been talking on, not just working on, over the past
few months.
Yeah.
We're still cooking lots of other stuff, you guys.
So...
Be a part of our story.
Yeah.
We are...
Aww...
Dance!
EXP!
E!
I almost started singing.
I keep doing this on stream as well.
I keep saying, EXP!
Wait, I almost did too, and I didn't realize that vocal
stimming to that would not be would not be good right now.
Soon, after today, we can vocal stim now.
Two hours left, guys, not to do it.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Cause I've been walking around my house just singing it.
And so my housemates know now they're like, something's
coming out.
They're like, they're like, but you're having fun.
I've never heard that thing before.
And I'm like, don't, don't, don't question it.
Don't even think about it.
Don't perceive it.
I'm just, I'm sitting there vocal stimming.
Hmm.
So they got the spoilers.
They got spoilers.
But they have no idea in particular, because of certain
theming for this project, I think, I think, like, certain
members of my household are going to really, really dig it.
But I think everyone will really dig it.
It's just, it's just so, there's something for everyone in
it, Yeah, I think it's a genre that's not really touched on
much in VTuber's sphere.
Yeah, right?
Yeah, I think that's definitely a thing.
Yeah.
It's going to be so special.
Yeah, I think a lot of people will Very be excited.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, no.
What do you guys think it is?
I'm kind of intrigued to it.
What do you think it is?
Yeah, actually, what do you think it is?
Especially those of you that recorded to...
I'm sorry about my funky sounding guides for the recordings,
but like, you got to hear a little bit of it through the
guides.
So like, what do you think?
What a country song?
Neha o'er.
Freestyle slam poetry.
Oh, what was this?
I mean, that would be really sick, actually.
but yeah that's like some my go stuff right there uh let's
see den set to full opera performance would be cool one day
as well vtuber psychological horror i think it'd be fun to
do like a horror arg one day that'd be really fun agree kids
song yeah yeah it's a skibby um baby shark uh yeah smash up
wheels on the bus don't do that one though you'll get you'll
get copyright struck for wheels on the bus i'm seeing a few
a few things in here that may apply actually a little bit i
i thought a little bit too a little bit right maybe like two
two comments oh three maybe three okay god durian eating
content is definitely not in there i can tell you that much
yansetsu.exe rom-com anime i'm seeing people say that it's a
cover that's so interesting wait that's that's very
interesting okay i guess Oh, you don't really...
I wonder if you...
I'm so bad at this.
You can say something.
You want to?
What?
Oh, I think he's typing.
Oh my god, I don't know why I just did.
Okay, I tried to do a question mark, but you know what I
mean?
I'm not ordering you guys to do this.
I just can't find a question mark.
I think we can though.
Say it.
Vampire.
I know what you are.
Say it.
Vampire.
God, Skull would be cool.
I would like a Densetsu Skull song one day.
That would be fun.
Oh, that's so cool.
We're not opposed to any genre.
So the world is our oyster.
Truly.
And we love oysters.
I never had one, actually.
I don't...
It's okay, I'll take that and your mushrooms too.
I'll take both of them.
Yeah, please!
Yeah.
I'll have the mushrooms.
I'll fight you for the mushrooms.
But you don't like Kino Kono Yama.
You love mushrooms, but you don't like Kino Kono Yama.
Listen.
I'm getting mixed signals from you.
Fakers!
You're the faker.
Not having it.
Yes.
not having it but yeah should we we could give them a clue
about yeah i think it's okay for us to say that i think it's
okay should we do a drum roll okay some information then
it's uh
who's gonna say it oh oh yeah go for it go for it the
patreon members should have expected it unless you thought
there was a cover song that we could have covered that had
freaking our name in it.
Who knows?
Maybe we're not the first We could have changed the lyrics
or something.
Yeah, we could have.
Well, yeah, our second original single is...
Well, at least the video for it is coming out today.
Tonight.
I don't know.
We don't know 100% yet when it's going to be on streaming.
But surely soon, because the song is definitely done,
obviously.
At least enjoy the video.
Give it lots of love.
And we're going to rate into it at the end.
So stick around to the end, okay?
Please!
We did the most effort.
There was so much effort and love that went into the song
and the video.
Maximum love.
We would really appreciate if you guys watched it and
streamed it lots and lots and lots.
Yeah!
Please, please!
You guys also won't be able to guess who the producer for it
was either.
You'll have to wait till the credits.
Just to find out who it was.
But it's a...
What I will say is it's a producer that is perfect for us.
Yeah.
So true.
Oh my gosh, you guys are going to be so hyped.
Also, in a...
Oh, wait.
That was about an hour.
In about 30 minutes.
Is that...
When we're doing something else?
Should we say that?
Oh, yeah.
We're going to have another big announcement.
Yes.
Wait, what's the second...
in a big announcement?
Can someone say Oh, it's the...
Yeah, uh...
Well, that's fun.
No, wait.
We should have just not told you, and then you would have
been surprised, too.
Oh, yeah.
I would be part...
I would be with everybody else.
I mean, that's kind of exciting.
I love surprises.
You know, like, when you order something, you pre-order
something, and then it ships to you, like, a year and a half
later, and you're like, what is this?
Yes!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the prize of Christmas.
But no, good second announcement.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
So we will do that in approximately 25 minutes or so.
We will stop and do another announcement.
Yes, indeed.
So stick around.
It's announcement Matsuri, guys.
Yeah.
Should we also say the other thing that will be happening on
stream?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's okay.
We...
Okay.
Oh, now Vicky's gonna be surprised.
Maybe I'll surprise Vicky, actually.
I'll say we have some of our friends calling in.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, we have some of our friends.
We love so much.
They'll call in and we'll talk with them a little bit.
So, yeah.
There were a lot of friends that wanted to make it, but
either because they're, like, traveling at the moment,
because they're not feeling well, they're not able to come,
but they send their love and we want to let them know that
we're still thinking of them and appreciate that they even
wanted to join us today at all.
You know who you are and we love you.
Yeah.
Yeah, there were many more people that we wanted to have,
but that's okay.
It was also kind of a spur of the moment thing.
Yeah.
Because we're definitely going to do our Q&A today, so
that's what we're going to do.
That's why I have this wheel up here.
for our Q&A.
So that's where I think.
I know, right.
We've been staring at it.
I've been staring at it for a while.
Me too.
It's just slowly spinning.
My name is so big on it.
Why is it you?
Tensetsu.exe, Victoria.
Mint.
Should we get started with question, or wait.
Yeah, we can get started with Q&A.
Yeah!
Let's do some questions!
Let's do it!
We did a couple of them before.
Yeah!
Second announcement?
Basically, between all of our scheduled activities, we'll
just answer more questions.
Let's- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, first spin...
I'm guessing, guys.
Whoa!
Oh, wow, it's beautiful.
Oh, bong bong!
Yeah!
Dance at you.
Dance at you at you at you at you!
Don't do, don't take the thing!
I was gonna do it!
Redacted, redacted.
You guys will understand, every time we say Densetsu.exe
now, we're gonna be so tempted.
So tempted.
The first question is...
Oh,
Daisuke.
Please, three of you are so lovely, so precious, Daisuke.
That's very sweet.
Is that a question?
I... Well, actually, um, actually, if you wanted to Oshi all
three of us, it would actually be Hakko Oshi, which is the
whole group.
So...
There you go.
Well, um, um, actually.
Do you have your little swirly glasses?
I wish you could put them on this model, too.
Oh, yeah.
Need your little swirly glasses.
You learned something new today.
Yeah.
But yes, please, please support us as a group.
Yes!
I would really love everyone to love Vicky and Mint and all
of us together.
Because I think as one, then we form one brain cell.
So like love the whole brain cell, not just a third of one.
I agree.
I think we're still half.
You still think we're only half?
Oh, well, we're a third of a half of a brain cell.
A third of a half.
It's more of six!
Oh, good job!
Good job, Vivi!
No, no, if they're working out that fraction alone, we're at
least a whole brain cell.
I'll never forget, Vicky, when we were planning that concert
trying to go to it, we both got the day wrong.
Phoebe, we're relying on you.
Oh, God.
A whole brain cell, please.
It's all on you, Phoebe.
It's all on you.
Oh, this is a heavy...
right now i've got the whole the whole brain cell on my back
right now but it's okay we will we will brain cell on her
back but that was that was a singular brain cell moment
right
we we we love it when you're a fan of all of us is this is
this question purple for a reason so we have like an
unofficial group color as well don't we they do i wonder if
people know about that we sort of vaguely are group color
purple i don't know yeah true yeah yeah because you can't
really like combine pink and green and blue to become a new
i mean it would turn into like a brown right yeah this is
brown brown could have so the contenders were brown and
purple i'm glad it's purple but i voted for brown sorry
I was thinking, I was thinking piss yellow at first, but
like...
Poopy brown?
Someone in the child's like, poopy brown.
Poopy brown!
Brown, brown, brown, and green at piss.
That just came, that just came out of your mouth.
What is going on here?
Oh my gosh.
And with that, should we go to another question?
Yes.
It's still green.
Thank you for the question, though.
Please, please diceky all of us because we diceky all of
you.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for loving the group.
Yippee!
It's, oh, oh, densest.exe.
Has another group question.
Should I, guys, do you think I should go in the order of
numbers or do you think I should just choose a random one.
Choose the one you like, maybe.
I feel like it might be easier for you to keep track if you
go on the number of orders.
Oh, that's true.
Okay, oh, you're right, you're right, because I'm going to
forget.
Then the next one is this.
D-U-F with clown girls.
I like clown girls.
Yeah.
Just get a band rep.
You know, they're just doing their job, and they are an
artist.
You know?
I think clowns should be appreciated.
Felt bad for people, like for clowns, like people being
scared of them.
Because aren't they trying to make people smile?
Typically.
Yeah.
There was just one bad egg, you guys.
Not all clowns.
Yeah.
But also, also, can I just tell a quick anecdote?
Like, the scariest thing that ever happened to me on
Halloween was like, I was walking around.
Yeah, well, there was a guy, it was around the time.
when like, when like people were dressing up as clowns and
being scary.
Do you remember when that was on the news?
Yeah.
Yes, yes, yes.
Walking around my school outside, and there was this guy
dressed up as a clown, and he had like a, he had like a bat
or something.
It was some kind of weapon.
And he like...
That is scary.
And then he chased me.
And he was like, it's a joke.
It's like, it's a prank, dude.
It's a prank.
And I was like, I'm just wearing my Doraemon onesie.
Please let me... Where is he?
You were victim to the clown?
The clown, the clown, the one bad egg came after.
No, no, no, no.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to track him down.
You don't do that to Phoebe.
The stream went down for a second.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, is it back?
It's back.
Yeah, we're back.
We're back.
Oh.
Hello.
Are we back?
I think we're back.
Oh, just seeing how I'm going to take that clown down.
I'm ready.
Ready for them.
too violent with how we said we were going to take him down
yeah i guess so they chased after our precious our precious
febe yeah oh thank you guys don't let the clowns that was
the clown that was the clown that took the stream down for a
second oh my god don't oh my gosh he was down to clown less
scary but i did have someone in the clown outfit turn up to
give me my uber eats and that was a bit creepy on my monitor
thing because i was just like oh okay cool and then they had
like full clown makeup on and i was like bro was it
halloween at all or closer just a normal day just a normal
day geez also thank you i can't say i've had any experiences
with clown real quick thank you phil for the 50 gifted
memberships 50.
oh thank you more denchis can use our cute emotes what were
you saying mental you haven't had a an experience Yet?
No, I don't think so.
Oh.
Hopefully if you do, it'll be a fun experience.
Yeah.
I don't know if your experience was fun.
Was it, Vicky?
Was it fun?
I'm not glad.
It was a bit surprising.
I don't think they were, like, I think they were pretty
chill, but it was just a bit surprising.
Yeah.
I think I can imagine in the moment.
I was like, wow.
Can imagine?
Yeah.
I do say I'm gonna become the Joker often though, so I
wonder...
Maybe you are gonna be the clown experience, yeah.
Yeah, me, yeah.
But no, love clown girl V-Tubers, you know?
All those fun clown V-Tubers, we love you.
Yeah.
So cute!
Yeah!
Oh, nice.
Thank you for your question.
Next one is gonna be a...
Hello.
Also, a densetsu.exe question.
Yeah.
Can you guys hear the clapping sound that it makes?
No.
Every time.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Our next question is...
Well, we kind of answered this earlier, so maybe I should
choose another one.
But, uh...
We did.
Go ahead.
But we can say it again.
No.
It doesn't.
Yeah.
And the way that it feels wrong.
way longer um because we've also been working on so much
behind the scenes you guys can't even we can't even we want
to spoil it i know we i know we want to spoil it but we
won't just how long we got one and a half hours guys we've
got to keep it together how many secrets can you hold before
you explode how many great question i do wonder well we'll
find out not very many
I think I'm good at keeping, like, people's secrets when
they're not mine, but when they're my secrets.
Oh, true.
I'm exactly the same.
Yeah, yeah.
I set the priority space for stuff that's not mine, then for
my stuff.
I'm just like, oh, dear.
Oh, my God, I don't want to go.
Oh, no.
Oh, dear.
Precisely.
Exactly.
I'm like, mm-mm.
It's all going to come out in my ears.
It's going to come out in my nose.
I'm shaking.
I'm just vibrating in our seats.
Oh my, wait, how long have you got, chat, for this question?
That's what I was thinking too.
Oh my god.
Yeah, this is gonna...
This is a...
This is a doozy.
It's a doozy.
It's a good question, but we have like 13 minutes until...
A little bit less than 13 minutes until the announcement,
and then Collins will start.
We could, like, give ourselves a time limit of, like, three
minutes.
to convince each other should I time it okay yeah okay will
we be convinced all right okay mental will go why three
minutes let me know when you want to start why should we
play MGS okay three two one go I am convincing Vicky and
Phoebe why they should play it Metal Gear Solid now first do
you like story yeah yes then you will love metal gear solid
there's the most story there's it's not even okay so i
always say that metal gear is like one of the most poorly
advertised games ever because it comes off as such a like a
like call of duty like i'm a serious military game but no
it's not it's so goofy it's so emotional it has literally
everything it is so like it's it's got suspense and surprise
and people pee on you And people pee their pants.
And...
What?
Alright, I'm sold, yes.
That was one of us.
And there's massive butts.
Vicky, there's snake's butt.
Literally, Kojima was like, I have to make it big because
you'll be staring at it.
Oh, my gosh.
He understands you.
I didn't know his butt was so big.
Wait.
Are you serious?
It is.
I have a figure I'll have to show you.
I've like seen a butt, but I wasn't sure if it was real or
shot.
But it's real.
You can confirm it's real.
It's real.
It's, it's, the game is just so charming.
Every single character is so fun.
Mine is like one or two.
But you know, it's fine.
There's gotta be the one or two.
Yeah, exactly.
But even then, everybody is so awesome and there's old men
and they fight and they're...
Half your time gobb.
What?
Time's up?
No, half your time.
Oh.
Halfway.
There is Old Man Yao-y.
It's very...
Yeah, I don't know what else to say.
There's a lot.
I don't want to spoil anything.
Yeah, that's true, actually.
Yeah, non-spoiler version for these is kind of difficult,
isn't it?
Right.
But what about the music?
I feel like the music I've heard is so good.
It's so good.
Oh, my gosh.
Every game has, like, an amazing song.
I've listened all the time.
The soundtrack, the OST itself, is so good.
I'm always quoting.
Even there's like one song in MGS2 that's the boss theme.
And it goes and I go around my house and I do that.
And it's so fun.
Something about eating tree frogs, too, right?
Something about, yeah, you can actually eat tree frogs.
You do eat them.
Yeah.
You have to to survive.
You have to.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Wow.
He truly is a snake.
And it makes you cry.
The series is so...
I cried so many times in that game.
It's so good, though.
It's so good.
Everybody's goofy.
Oh, there's a guy.
His name is Vamp.
But not because he's a vampire.
Though he does suck blood.
But his name is Vamp because he's bisexual.
What?
I don't see the connection.
But I'm convinced.
I am extremely convinced.
And I'll go like the thing that is sticking out in my mind
is Snake's massive butt.
And I feel like I need to investigate it pronto.
What about you, Phoebe?
I'll get the figure, a picture of the figure for you.
The Spark Notes version in my brain is...
But, and peeing.
Silly little guys and eating tree frogs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It kind of sounds just like...
It sounds like...
potty humor against a very cool military-esque setting which
like sounds fun oh damn oh damn wait sorry i just got the
picture in discord oh wait multi-multi-a whoa whoa wait he
is the tree Wow.
Wow.
For anybody who knows, it's...
Like how you have multiple angles.
It's the picture, it's the old snake figure from MGS4.
Um, if you know, you know.
I didn't think old guys could have a, have, have, have a
beehine like that, you know?
Wow.
I'm impressed.
He's the best to ever do it, maybe.
Well, maybe.
Or you'll be behind.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
Anyway, right.
Sonic Adventure 2.
Because we don't have much time left.
Who's going next?
Shall I go next, Phoebe?
Yes.
Okay.
Guys, the characters in Sonic are the main thing that I want
to convince you to play Sonic Adventure 2.
Also, the music.
First thing into the game, game you get city escape amazing
level okay the dialogue is great no food or movies i'm out
of here you see sonic's personality instantly the song
absolute banger the level you know if you master to get the
high ranks it's really fun to go through that level really
quickly there are three types of modes you're either having
your egg man and tails like shooting mode you're having your
sonic and shadow fast mode all my favorite knuckles and
rouge treasure hunting now the knuckles especially in two
player.
I love it.
That's my favorite one personally.
Also, all of Knuckles's levels have a sick rap song as well.
You just can't get it out of your head.
It's so good.
Also, the dialogue is amazing.
Particularly the Sonado dialogue in Sonic Adventure 2 is
incredible.
Also, there are so many things that don't make any sense,
such as Rouge falling into lava.
She is a bat.
She can fly.
Okay.
True.
There are so many things that don't make any sense.
any sense but it's great and genuinely the plot that goes
out through Sonic Adventure 2 is actually incredible like
the whole thing with like Shadow and Maria and you know how
he feels about the and how his character progresses through
the game is actually incredible and one of the reasons why
Shadow is my favorite character is because of his character
progression in Sonic Adventure 2 and how he takes his pain
from his past and turns it into his strength, guys, okay?
And just the way that each of the characters interact with
each other, I think is what makes the Sonic franchise in
general so special.
Also, please don't hate it because of the camera.
Just get through the camera, guys.
Just get through it, okay?
You will not regret it.
Also, don't forget to get Knuckles' special equipment that
lets him breathe underwater because otherwise he will die in
the final level.
Thank you!
You forgot the one thing that would have convinced me
automatically, which is...
Chow Garden, you guys!
Chow Garden!
Oh yeah!
Also Chow Garden, also Chow Garden.
Are you having a treasure hunt?
I don't know, that's not so fun.
Those are the funnest levels, honestly.
Yeah, so good.
Oh my gosh.
You did so well.
Wait, wait, Maiden, have you played it?
I know Vibi definitely has played it.
No, I haven't.
I've only played Sonic 1 and 2.
Oh, so you've only been on Classic.
That's so cool.
It is so cool.
Sega Genesis that I played it on.
You haven't experienced Chao.
No, I haven't.
Classic Sonic and like quote unquote modern Sonic, although
it's not really modern anymore.
It's two very different experiences, so I would highly
recommend that you check those out as well.
Yeah, I'm excited.
I can't wait for my Sonic arc.
It will happen one day.
Yeah.
It's now gonna be... I'm so excited for your Sonic arc.
I'm so excited.
We have to see if you ship the same things as us too.
I'm in my Devil May Cry arc right now, guys.
Oh, you are.
Yeah.
It's very hype.
Okay, Phoebe, two minutes.
You ready?
Yes.
Near Automata.
Okay.
Three, two, one, go.
Do you guys like crying?
Yeah!
Do you like laughing?
Crying and laughing are two of the most human emotions, and
they come out so well in Yokotaro's writing in Near
Automata, despite the fact that it is in direct
juxtaposition with the fact that they are all automatons
hence automata oh they're so oh it's so it gets so into
philosophy which is why there are different robots that are
named after different philosophers like pascal and stuff
like that oh but but let me let's i won't get into that
first first of all the music is incredible because yokotaro
always works with one of my favorite monaka monaka composers
keichi okabe san who is incredible who's done music for all
kinds of things before like uh Yuna is a hero and and like
uh, the whole draking guard series and and stuff like that
and and it's and it's really Incredible and the music
actually there's like adaptive adaptive like like game sound
design in it So like if you go into different areas
according to if it's like in a battle mode or not Um, the
it'll be the same song, but it'll add more instruments in
it's really really freaking cool I love that right super
immersive the world building is wonderful the characters are
wonderful.
There's also fantastic ass because Yokotaro also figured
that you're going to be staring at Toobie's ass the entire
time.
Therefore...
Hold up.
I'm convinced.
Yeah.
It's always an ass with you, but yes.
And then, and then, um, 9S is my favorite character, and
he's a good, good boy.
He is such a good, good boy.
And he suffers.
And as we all suffer, there are a million, a bajillion
endings, and some of them are crack endings, and they're
fantastic.
Um, you will laugh.
You will cry.
You will question your own existence.
and you will become you will become as human yes it is it is
oh yeah yeah there's also bullet hell segments as well oh
that's a time up phoebe chan chibi i'm convinced i'm
convinced can i just just to confirm that can i have another
um picture of the ass please like mince oh yeah let me go
get She's so 2B ass.
2B butt.
Oh, why am I?
This is gonna take...
Oh, why is everything...
Everything is blurred out on my Google search.
Uh, don't worry.
No, here, I got you.
2B later.
No, I found one on Reddit.
Here you go.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm in baby mode, I guess.
Oh, damn.
Um, normally she's got a skirt on that, but you can take it
off.
Wow.
Wow, okay.
I'm convinced.
I'm convinced by both of you thoroughly.
That that's what it took.
Well, thank you for this question.
I was really wonderful hearing about everyone's favorite
games.
Um, yeah!
Yeah!
It was so much fun.
Um, that said though.
Oh god, I've made a mistake.
Have you?
I felt like I needed to prove something with Sonic, so I
decided to look up Big the Cat ass.
I regret it!
It's not a competition, it's fine!
You've convinced us without the power of act!
Anyway!
We have one minute until the announcement.
Yes, though it's also the same time that a certain friend of
ours is supposed to be calling in.
So let's start right now.
Let's start the announcements.
Yeah, okay.
If you're okay with that.
Well, actually, I forgot to do that.
this earlier uh real quick oh as a reminder our spring merch
and voice packs with beasties are still on sale just for
today though like just for today today is the last few hours
now so please go go go go check those out um go go go go go
go go go go and and and and and yeah and then but but our
real announcement that we're going to make for today is
Look at this key visual you got!
Over the reveal as well as streaming tickets are available
now and a digital message board for the concert!
Digital message board!
And those messages are going to be shown during the concert
on the big screen.
So...
Yeah!
Please go check them out at legendsanew.com if you missed
out on getting your in-person tickets for Legends Anew or
you just live really, really far away.
are your way to go they are unlimited so go get them go get
them go get them legends and new.com yay yeah go go go go go
let's take a look at the key visuals so cute oh it's so i
love the like background in akihara so pretty look you could
see mega turnip over there you could see made mince cafe
right there oh you can see well the live house is supposed
to be mine but like i I'm kind of... I live outside.
I live outdoors.
I don't have a house.
There's the flowers right above the mega turnip.
Yeah!
Oh, but yeah, there's flowers above the mega turnip.
When I thought about it more, I was like, I love this world.
Everybody's places are here.
Wait, I don't have a home.
I live in the park outside.
Flowers outside both of our places that you can always hop
to and from.
You can just sit in there.
I can sit with the flowers.
Yeah.
But look how cute everyone is.
Oh, so beautiful.
Walking through the streets as we take Akiba.
We're taking Akiba.
We're taking it.
Look how adorable everybody is.
The art is so pretty.
Vicky's got...
So pretty.
Vicky's doing a Vicky Punch.
Vicky Punch.
I love our poses.
So cute.
I love Mentos like...
Yeah, you're saying howdy.
I'm saying howdy.
I love your thing.
Your thing always gives me...
Gives me like...
Gives me life.
every time I see it.
Yes.
I like how artists just know to draw me in the Kira, the
Runkka pose.
Yeah, I was gonna say you're famous Kira.
Yeah.
Popularized by Phoebe Chan.
Did you guys know it also is sign language for I love you
though?
And I love you a lot.
Yeah, I love you so much.
Wait, that's so cute.
Aww.
And yeah, please enjoy.
Um, this adorable...
Ta-da!
Um...
work for the for the concert and go right on the digital
message board and get your stream tickets everybody we will
have uh we'll have someone pin the link in the chat someone
will do it surely or i will do it and surely anyone from
staff is watching our on the website the visuals on the
website oh the visuals on the website it's It's so pretty!
What is it?
Oh is it?
Yeah!
Dove Robertson and TVTableTree.
Thank you so much for the gifted!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, it really is.
It's so pretty!
Leg...
Legs...
Legends.
Legs are new.
There you go.
It is now pinned.
Ta-da-da!
Or I think I did it.
Hopefully.
Wow!
Oh, it looks so nice on the website.
Wasn't it?
Oh, it's...
Oh!
So pretty.
You know, our color scheme is the cutest color scheme.
Can I just say that?
I think so too.
Aww.
Also, we are just about to, so please get hyped for this
announcement, but also we're just about to do our call-ins.
Our first guest is waiting for us already.
Yeah, I see you're waiting.
We will be right over to the other.
So we should hop over there, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Got it.
yeah so we're gonna hop into it yes do the the live chat
yeah okay okay see you see you over there see you in there
hello hello can you hear me for everybody else and then let
me get the foogai foogai foogui foogui Fuki Actually, I
think I'm going to have to do it when they come in Let me
drag them in Oh, wait, wait, wait Actually, unless You can
go to be right back screen if you want Oh, yeah, I'm going
to go to BRB screen Do I have a BRB screen?
I will I will be right We'll be right back Okay Real quick,
BRB
Hello It's MVP You guys Big
fan Look at me I have my I have my glow stick And everything
Glow stick Is that a glow stick?
Yeah my lollipop Yeah Yeah It counts It counts It's got all
our colors on it I'm kind of concerned For eating that Yeah
Don't worry about it The shirt really sells it Yeah I do
like my minion shirt But I like your spinny hat Can you fly
with it?
Thank you Does it spin so fast that you hover?
Beryl bug.
Do you want to do an introduction just in case somebody
doesn't know?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry, I totally do.
I totally blame.
Hi, everybody.
My name is
part of Beasties.
Not Densetsu.
I'm part of Beasties, please.
Such a cute bug.
And we love Beasties so much.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Welcome in Barald Ball.
Yes!
Um, thank you so much for joining us.
Oh, you know, you know, if you ever want to be an idol for a
day or something, though, um, surely we'd be able to be
MVP-B for a little bit.
You can take my clothes.
Wait, where's her chair?
Oh my god.
Our cosplay is Mint, and I'll be like, Hi guys, it's me,
Mint.
Moe, Moe, bug.
Moe, moe, bug.
People are asking where your chair is, so I'm going to get
you a little chair to sit in.
No, no, no.
Oh, yeah.
Thank you for getting me a comfy chair, at least, I guess.
It's so big, yeah.
No, Mary's just that small.
We love little- We love silly little guys here, though.
We love silly little guys.
No, no, I'm seven feet tall.
Then that's a really big chair.
But happy six months!
Thank you for having me!
Thank you!
Thanks for joining!
Yeah, me freaking clamoring for the first spot in the
Collins, like...
You were going against so many other people.
Wait!
I beat Matara Khan, and that's all that matters, baby.
This is true, actually!
This is true!
We're gonna have so many bugs in here.
We love our little bug friends.
Or sorry, big bug friends.
Infestation.
Infestation is true.
It's Tara with the frowny face.
We love you, Matara.
I'm gonna ban her, but use her now.
Oh my god.
Does Beasties have an anniversary day?
Um, I think we do.
We formed a little bit later than you guys, so I think it's
like in a month, maybe?
It's coming up!
I have to double check.
Excited.
Oh, you guys are celebrating your six months as well.
Yeah.
Thank you.
We're doing it.
We're making it.
We're here.
Six months.
We're doing it, guys.
Yeah.
Somehow.
We really survived.
Somehow, some way we did it.
We did it.
So proud of you guys, too.
Oh, my god, yes Please, please, please, please I've been
literally waiting, I've been waiting my DMs Every time I see
you, I see you, Shane, I'm just like Oh my god, oh my god
It's a hair flick, I caught I just caught, Barry I just
caught It makes so much sense that you like Virgil too It's
so awesome Oh, you like Virgil, yeah!
Are you Team Virgil?
I mean, you're so cool!
I still have that acrylic stand of Nero I have to give you
wait that that stand is crazy i don't know like i don't know
if i'm brave enough to like weather like receiving it to be
honest they did like a they did like a summer devil may cry
uh like a merch drop at the capcom store and i pulled i
pulled sexy shirtless nero oh everybody in that drop has
like six pack like six two It's like an eight pack.
It's crazy.
Yeah, it's crazy.
If you don't want it, I'll take it.
Wait, no, if Mitara wants it, I want it.
Hold on.
Wait, give it to me.
Is Virgil all of your guys' favorites from Devil May Cry?
I mean, I've already played the first one.
Yeah, I like another protagonist that comes later, but...
Virgil is not my favorite, I'm sorry.
But I do like him.
There seems to be a lot of cool characters.
Yeah, you don't know yet, huh?
You don't know him yet.
Yeah, you know, I've got time.
I'm only on my first game, so we'll see who my favorite is.
So far, it's Virgil.
So far, I'm like, oh, okay.
I feel like you'll like someone else later down.
Oh, really?
Oh, okay.
Do you know who I'm talking about?
Dude.
The one experience I have with Devil May Cry is actually
with five.
I'm sorry that I skipped to five.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
But you're the most approachable.
It was because like a house made of my own.
You like the guy in five?
I like, I like a certain person in five.
Oh no, that's the same one.
Wait.
Are we the same?
That's fucking crazy.
Oh my god.
Is it me?
Well, I guess you'll just have to find out.
We'll have to find more out.
Yeah, we'll find out.
I'm excited.
We'll find out.
It's so awesome learning about which character the girls
like the most because it's like, oh, I know so much about
your taste now.
It says a lot, huh?
It does say a lot.
It does say a lot depending on which guy you choose.
guys i think i really started to like virgil though because
of his voice in oh gosh which one was it that like it
sounded like the voice actor had a cold and so he can't oh
it's three three yeah yeah yeah oh i was like this it's so
it's so awesome he has so much freaking gap moey dude i know
scum so good yeah i was like i was like call me scum Okay,
wait.
We have entirely different reasons for saying that this is
like, this is the Barry personality quiz.
And now I feel like I'm learning so much about you guys.
It is the personality quiz.
It is.
Vicky, I saw you like being called Scrum, huh?
I like how we were like, we were like, what?
Oh, we need to tell Barry to go in the call.
So I sent, I sent us like a Devil May Cry gif and then chant
in the call.
It was like, I'll bring you in.
a batman symbol but for barrybug yes yes
everyone should play dmc now we do thank you i will be i
will be a cheerer a densetsu a denshi forever if there is
one denshi that is me if there is zero i am dead there is
zero you are barrybug yes no no we we will always support
you and be very bug fans and be beastie fans as well we'll
support each other we'll support each other i can't wait to
see i can't wait to see uh all all everything i don't want
to say anything that you haven't announced but i can't wait
to see everything you've been working on and and all your
hard work cut to fruition and thank you thank you i hope you
guys sell out more billion times and get a more billion
dollars and and and get and get rich and and budokan and and
everything and budokan oh oh well then we're getting you in
front row front row very oh hell yeah i'll be front row i'll
be like cheering with my light sticks i'll be like yes thank
you so much thank you yeah thank you so excited for all the
things that you and beasties have planned to and for your
upcoming six month anniversary you guys are you guys are
crushing it i'm so excited for everything you're gonna do do
as well yeah thank you you guys are doing so well too i
can't wait to see everything you have in store i will be i
will be watching very intently i'll be looking with my bald
eyes we're always watching we're watching i stared at the
abyss and they stared back help help we're like gazing we
should do more beasties then sets to collapse we should yes
yes yes people really enjoyed that lab that we did.
Though maybe not trivia next time, No, no.
Trivia is so much fun.
I mean, I love it, but also I knew how to answer the
questions about vegetables and about cryptids, and that was
about...
We lost London, or UK quiz to...
Yeah.
Well, no, didn't I lose to peel?
Yeah!
That's You were supposed to be...
You were the chosen one.
Fake British.
She was low on her supply on Greg's sausages, so that's why
she lost.
She was low.
Oh, true.
Made my point of supply to keep up my Britishness, yeah.
Oh, man.
Groove.
Come on, Greg.
Sponsor Vicky.
Come on, please.
Lifetime's alive.
Please.
Greg's to Japan win.
Chicken Bakes for life.
Actually, Greg's Japan win.
Barry.
we love you yeah yeah love you Barry love you Barry thank
you yeah thank you for having me happy six months again I
love you guys so much we love you this is who forever MVP
for I'm too shy I'm too shy thanks for joining us another
bug is banging on the door there is another bug banging on
the door right now unfortunately we must say goodbye but
maybe we'll have both bugs in here what if we just drag her
in right now what if we just i'm terrified we could do that
something's gonna start something's gonna start uh well
you're gonna you're gonna get back to stream anyway but yeah
yeah you're on stream i could go on i don't i don't mind oh
wait i do want to see what matara will will like say Okay,
wait, then let's ping her.
Uh, feel free to join whenever.
Hello!
Oh!
Anniversary!
Hi!
I have a time out of here too!
Hi girls, I'm so happy for you.
What the heck?
Can you make me a little bit bigger on the left?
But like, bigger.
Bigger.
Like more than the left.
Like, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, that's good, that's good.
Yeah, yeah, like that, right?
No!
Like, like this.
Can you just put me a little bit more in front?
A little bit more in front?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Like that?
Yeah, that, yeah, yeah, that's perfect.
Perfect.
happy six actually anniversaries for a year happy six months
i was watching i was cheering you on i was finding tips and
tricks on how to how to exterminate smaller bugs you know
but yeah
no matara ate her the bigger bug ate the smaller one
honestly girl such as nature yeah exactly if ever your girls
need a trick to like get buried to do something just tell me
i'll be like wow I sure love eating broccoli, you know, and
she'll be like, oh, I love it more.
If Watarra loves broccoli, I love it more.
Because I said that if she didn't want her stand D, I said
that I'll take it.
And she goes, if Watarra wants it, I want it.
Oh, yeah.
So if you ever need to, like, trick her to do anything, just
let me know, okay?
Okay.
Oh, thank you so much, Watarra.
Thank you.
I am so excited for your girls' 3D live over at Off Pie.
there oh yeah so excited i'm i'm gonna be cheering so loud
you actually might hear me from the crowd i believe that
actually oh my god how do you girls feel about it how are
you excited nervous how are you oh incredibly excited yeah i
can't even hold in my excitement i'm nervous i'm nervous
yeah why why are you nervous what's up because it's a lot
but i'm i'm excited more excited than neighbors so okay
that's good that's good and hey who knows maybe this this
concert is going to be the start of of a world tour oh oh
that would be crazy yeah maybe winky winky winky winky winky
she's she's saying things that we don't even know oh like
winky face sorry i actually i i touched grass today so now
i'm like a little bit like the opposite of you know an
internet dweller wow what's what is the grass like how
inspiring it's actually sand because i live by the beach oh
my god my grass is sand oh yes girls i just need you to know
that i will forever be your groupie um and i will forever be
following around and if ever you need help like loading bags
onto the truck or like beating people up or like you know
showing showing my booba i will throw my bra on stage wow
wow oh my gosh well that's the real rock star treatment
right there that wow exactly exactly if ever you need oh if
ever oh yeah i i'm so excited for you as well sorry no sorry
every single performance ladies that would be that would be
lovely we'll just have a collection we'll put it up on the
wall in the in the dentist office have you so currently what
have you um announced that we we know about that we can we
can be excited about i saw you girls at like the website pop
post today with streaming tickets and things like that yes
we have special guests as well such as me i have i brought a
critically acclaimed Japanese singer Asaka.
I saw you.
Yeah.
Do you guys want to say who you brought?
Yeah, the amazing Demon Dice is going to be performing with
you.
And I brought a special friend who I look up to very, very
much as both a person and as a singer, the Iron Mouse.
Let's go!
I don't know if Asa is a demon, but, you know, she might as
well be.
Oh, do you have a demon going on there?
Demon, demon.
I'm going to say as well, Mataro, so excited for the
fantastic reality.
Yeah.
With you?
With you, girls, for lending me your powers and helping me
so much with it.
It's going to be my first time, so I feel like I'm absorbing
your idol goodness, you know?
You are going to be so dazzling.
Like, I think I'm going to cry probably.
I do plan to scream very loud for you.
You should, you know, usually I'd say don't cry, but no.
You should cry a little bit.
It's nice.
I like it.
Makes me feel nice and loved.
I know how you feel.
Don't you just, like, want to make people cry?
Like, sometimes I'm like, that's my life mission.
It's something that people cry.
But from, like, a good space, you know, like a good, like a
good, happy cry.
I'm like, oh, I'm so happy for you.
That's going to be me at Your Girls' Show at Off-Kai.
I'm gonna be there crying, being like, I'm so glad they
stayed together.
I'm so glad they're performing.
I know that you've gone through a lot with, you know, your
singing and your confidence and your singing abilities.
I'm just so proud of you for, you know, you're finally on
the stage and you're gonna kill it and you're gonna have so
much fun and you're gonna, you're gonna shine!
Yes!
For a second when you were saying that, I was like, my
confidence.
But you met my confidence with singing.
Yeah, no, not my regular confidence is fine.
But speaking of confidence, I'm so excited to meet both
Phoebe and Victoria.
I haven't had the pleasure of meeting you yet, but I've had
the pleasure of meeting Steiner.
And he said very, very great things.
He said lovely things about you both.
So I'm very excited to one day meet you both and give y'all
a big hug.
Oh, likewise.
Been really looking forward to it.
I had a displeasure of seeing Matara, so.
You love me.
you love me i i i asked mint i was like can i can i please
pinch your butt and she said yes and it was great oh i asked
permission you know but um yeah with that said girls i am
cheering you on i am rooting for you as i said um i i talked
to steiner when i when i met him and i asked about like you
know how come you girls stay together what's what's up and
i'm just so happy that you all collectively to give us this
VTuber idol group for us to cheer for because I think the
VTuber space was really missing something like this and I'm
really really glad to see the three of you working so hard
and and singing so well and maybe allegedly I have been
teased an upcoming project of yours and you all sound
incredible and I just I'm so excited for it might be the
thing premiering
that you are enjoying it already isn't it great it's crazy
she was laughing the entire time you need to release the cut
like the the whatever cut you need to release it
yeah but i just and i was telling mint right like i've known
mint for a long time and it's just so cool to hear mint
shine in a group with other people who are also shining and
working hard and and everybody's kind of chasing the same
dream collectively so instead of competing you're kind of
like pushing each other up it it it really honestly warms my
heart and i just wanted to say thank you to you girls for
choosing to stay together because i think vtubing really
needed something like this so thank you i didn't cry cry
come on but i hope you have such an incredible anniversary
today um and yeah i'll be seeing you girls and i'll be
seeing all the fans at your show over at offcott i think
it's already more than sold out but if there's any streaming
tickets anything else where can we get those oh yeah they're
streaming tickets you can get them in the pinned link uh in
the comments wait there's no pinned link legends and new.com
yeah there is he's a point sorry he's all right i just i
found the main location it's now at the bottom for some
reason.
I know.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
I just woke up looking up at the top and I couldn't find it.
Yeah.
I don't.
YouTube made a stupid change for no reason.
Alright, girlies, I give you so much love.
One day I'm going to give you big hugs and I'm rooting for
you and I'm cheering for you, okay?
Thank you so much.
Thank you, my top.
We've always cheering for you too.
Also, girls, you have to play Metal Gear.
It's really good.
You have to.
One of my favorite characters is in two and he's incredible
and and there's just it's just great you have to get through
three I know but yeah there's just please please play it I
mean I was already convinced by the ass but now I'm even
more wait I'm gonna I'm gonna send you all a photo later of
like oh I just I just have a screen grab of a character wait
is it gonna be a spoiler if I send them you know when he's
like send it to me first yeah it's it's exactly the photo
you think it is uh i actually have no idea what photo you're
thinking of oh god what's that oh sorry wait is anybody
after me or can i look for the photo for like three seconds
there's nobody yeah yeah yeah one second one second one
second this is uh you've uh you've got me You've got me
looking for it.
I'm like mouth breathing.
Think about that part in two that like would make me be
like, I'm thinking?
Cartwheels?
Oh!
Okay, that's what I thought.
I don't think it's exactly a spoiler.
I think it's fine.
Are you gonna show his butt?
What?
No, not his butt.
just his front where he's like covering his his no i think
you can show his butt well no i i have a photo saved on my
phone context for this no no you know i love not knowing
what's going on it just it really makes me so happy when i
have no idea what's happening
maybe i take too many photos i'm like not finding it she has
it saved i'm gonna send I'll send one of his butt then.
Oh.
Please, send it where I can see it, okay?
And tag me.
If you don't mind.
Tag me, if you don't mind.
It's not in his butt, everybody.
Oh my god, yeah.
Okay, so my photo is that, but like, from the front.
What?
From the...
I don't know if I want to see it from the front.
No, no, no, he's covering.
Oh, he is.
Convenient sensory.
No.
You can't just not share with the staff.
Um, you know what, should I put it up?
I think you can.
I think you could show them, but...
If you play the game, he literally is running around like
this.
What do you guys think?
Show them.
Okay.
Okay, I'm downloading it.
Show them.
Show them at all.
Now it's on your computer, Phoebe.
It was on my computer.
Ah!
It was the Trojan riding.
You guys Wow Wow Wow Look at his little book So there's a
really good explanation as to why he's naked You're gonna
have to play the game Yep yep yep Okay Does it help?
Okay I cannot find it Maybe But ladies I love you very much
I will find it and I will send it okay Okay Oh boy We're all
looking forward to it I'm looking forward to hugging you
mostly But but but but i guess also this probably oh this oh
this photo yeah yeah are you wait um phoebe and victoria are
you huggers or are you kind of like it's fine i'm a snuggler
yeah you're definitely a hugger phoebe yeah i would say i'm
a hugger sometimes you're like you're like maybe like a half
a hug sometimes okay yeah that's awesome all right ladies
big love big kisses have fun tonight okay thank you so
much oh lovely friends sweet wait if you're only a hugger
sometimes i'm sorry that i'm always going in for the hugs
with you like no no no i love i love no yeah it's all good i
feel like i'm just i'm the kind of person that i don't
really hug people myself but if someone hugs me I'm happy to
receive but I'm a bit of a shy hugger does that make sense
that makes sense a bit of a British hugger people just like
Vicky's just British I guess that is it I don't know like if
I get hugged then then I gratefully accept but I'm not often
the person to hug someone so that makes sense yeah I think
so I love hugging you guys though I think I'm the same yeah
uh I see so so I'm in you guys are the the hug uke's that
must be happily receive hug anytime she found it she found
it oh wow should i bring it up on the screen for everyone to
see it looks like she took a photo of her monitor she took a
photo of her monitor is that like a a thumb at the top or
something oh here guys i'll bring up the picture Whoa, oh,
it's so big.
Why is it so big?
There.
Oh my god.
She took a screenshot of her, a picture of her screen.
You can see the recording thing on the bottom.
She doesn't screenshot stuff.
Why is, but why, why though?
Why?
I'm not even questioning why you guys have these pictures.
It's a very important reason why he's naked.
I see.
In the kitchen as well, looks fine.
Yeah, in the kitchen?
Yeah, he's like, yeah, in the kitchen.
He's doing the naked cooking thing.
I'm not sure if this is hygienic or not.
Or maybe it's extra hygienic.
Who knows?
I don't know.
If there's grease though, it might pop and get on you.
Oh, who knows?
Maybe it gives him a thrill.
Maybe like...
What a thrill.
Oh, but we love, we love Matara and Ferry.
and we're so happy they could join us today.
There were several others, several others, especially from
Beasties, that want us to join today as well.
But literally, Pia, for example, cannot connect because
internet things currently.
But they would love to be here, and we're thinking of them
lots.
There will be more guests.
Did that guest happen to say that they're okay with moving
it?
Yes.
Some have said okay, some still waiting.
But it seems like it will be fine.
Okay.
I will keep you guys updated.
I will for now copy paste them into the other slot.
There you go.
But yes, that means that we are able to right now get back
to some questions.
Q's and A's.
Oh, question time.
Yes.
How are you guys feeling?
We just did some call-ins with Friendles and we did that
announcement about the stream tickets and the message board.
Chad, how are you feeling and Mint and Vicky, how are you
feeling about all this?
I'm going to bring up the visual again.
I'm going to stare at it.
I'm so excited!
I'm feeling fantastic.
Yeah.
Oh, it looks so good.
Oh, my gosh.
And don't forget, everybody get hyped for the original song
premiere in about 20-ish minutes, right?
Or no.
Or 40 minutes?
One hour.
One hour ish.
In one hour.
53 minutes.
Yeah.
So stick around for at least 55 more minutes, you guys.
Girl math.
Let's go.
I did it.
I did it, guys.
You did it.
You're proud.
The brain cell is working.
Math degree coming into you.
I'm going to go get some water real quick.
Go get the water.
Go get it.
I'll be right back then.
Yeah, you get it.
You get it.
Get that water.
I want to also drink some water.
I have like a tiny bit left in my water bottle.
Keep hydrated.
60, no, not 67 minutes.
Uh, no.
Best you could do is forever.
Oh, oh, forever.
And ever.
Forever, what?
Oh, dreaming.
Because then you never get the premiere.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
True.
Yeah, guys, don't you want the premiere?
Happy six months from the Church of Apusirf.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
you're the, you're the, you're the Apusia fairy that puts
super, a free super chats onto people's pillows at night.
Oh, that's a wonderful role.
Hi, Minto.
Welcome back.
Hello.
What's the church?
No, no, no, no.
Don't worry about it.
Please don't worry about it.
Welcome to the church of Apusir, my child.
Allow me to bless you.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
You've been blessed.
You're welcome.
You too, Vicky, are allowed to repent and join the church of
Apusir if you'd like.
No, I'm good.
I'm good being part of Apus Diap.
Thank you so much.
Up, who's D up?
Up, who I did it?
It's pretty super, super chat.
Don't worry, don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it.
Okay, right, guys, questions.
Let's, let's, let's end this line of chat.
Okay, questions.
Questions.
Okay.
Let's do another roll.
D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-dddd.
The board is rigged.
Then set to dot E-X-E.
One hour left.
This is a fun question.
What were your first impressions when you first heard of the
other two?
And how did it change once you became friends with them?
Ooh.
Who wants to go first?
This is an intro.
So, like, first impressions of, like, before we kind of,
like, like first impression when I saw you guys around on
the internet?
I think so.
I guess so, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Well, I remember the, I think the first time with Minto,
like I saw this funny, freaky clip.
I can't remember what that was.
But it was something funny and freaky and I thought, wow,
she's hilarious.
And then I went and I looked at her covers and I was like,
wow, her voice is so beautiful as well.
she's so nice I like her very much and then Phoebe I think
it was like a IRL thing that you did and then I watched like
your documentary and stuff as well and I was like wow she's
so inspiring and she's like doing her best towards her dream
and I thought both both these gals are so like I don't know
like really chasing chasing their dreams chasing things that
they want and they seem really nice and I was like admiring
from afar and then everything happened so Yeah, always,
always been admiring you guys.
Yeah.
Wow.
Can I go next?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think it's the same.
I've always, always thought you guys were cool.
And so, like, the fact that it was this combination of
little guys is, like, is kind of the best.
So, like, with Minto, I mean, I think I'd, I'd, like, like,
we go way back because, like, we were in 2020.
We both had the same V-Tuber mama.
And we debuted around the same.
Both of our six-year V-Tuber anniversaries are coming up.
Like next month, right?
Or sorry, next month?
July.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um, yours was like a week after mine, I think.
So it was about the same time.
Exactly the same time.
Um, and I was, I just thought you were so, so, so super
cute.
And I thought you were adorable.
I loved your voice, actually.
Your talking voice, I heard first, before any singing or
anything like that.
And I was like, it, it, it, like, soothes my soul.
It feels fluffy in my heart.
That sounds so different now, though.
I was thinking about that the other day.
I was like, we both kind of sound quite different than we
first, than when we first started streaming.
Because I mean, I mean, at least for me, I was quite shy
when I first started out.
definitely translated in the way that I would talk on
stream.
And it's developed a lot and I got to from there see all the
adventures that you went on and I was so proud of you.
I was like, ah yes, yes a fellow voter as well.
Yeah!
Oh yeah!
And then when this ended up happening, I was just like oh,
who better to chase dreams with, honestly.
And then with Vicky, Vicky, I would see around also on the
feed because specifically there was a...
There was a...
It was one of your singing...
Singings that you posted up and I thought your voice was
absolutely gorgeous.
But I also noticed that you liked a lot of Sonic things.
So I was like...
So I was like, oh my gosh, what a pretty voice!
Oh, and she's so good at Japanese and...
Oh, she's so cool.
She's also very idle too.
But then, um, then I then I saw your Sonic stuff and I was
like, whoa, this is like, this is another part of her that I
did not realize.
She would be really, really fun to talk with, I think.
Ah, I'm glad you thought that.
I never thought we were going to interact.
Well, like, for Minto, I just didn't think we would, like,
ever get a chance to interact very often.
And then for Vicky, I just never thought that I'd ever get a
chance to properly meet you.
So this, like, it ended up feeling very, very faithful.
this is the perfect combination of people for this group.
I truly do believe it's very faithful.
I think our voices and personalities just mesh so well.
Those are those things.
And interests and stuff too.
What are the chances of all of those things aligning?
Right.
Not very often.
For me, for me with Phoebe, you know, even before V2Bing, I
knew about you.
And I always I looked up to you so much you know you you you
are an idol you know you you shine on stage you are so
you're so passionate about what you do and you know I always
just admired you so much and how hardworking you are and so
you know I was always like man I gotta work harder Phoebe's
working so hard you know so um I was really happy too like
by coincidence that we had the same vtuber mama and
everything it felt like it felt like the the ball the the
ball of fate started rolling there and it was it was like a
little you know it took a while to pick it up but you know
um we're here where we are now and with vicky i you know i
had heard about you as well i didn't know you so much but
you know through through other friends mutuals i heard how
working you were i heard only everything amazing to hear
about you and knowing you now like oh my gosh i think that
10 times a hundred times like you do you do so much and you
are so good at everything that you do and it's really just
inspiring to see like how how good you are and like how how
awesome you are and i really look up to that because i'm
like oh my gosh vicky so cool
No!
Don't you guys think that, like, getting to know each other
better, your hearts are so beautiful.
That's something that I only, like, was able to, like, learn
fully after getting to know you was that you guys are such
good people, legitimately.
Like, I'm so...
I think now knowing you guys closer, I think I thought both
of you, like, you know, I still have the cool image of Vicky
and I still have the so sweet and pure image of Phoebe.
I think you guys are much worse.
I think you are degenerates.
Wow, I'm sitting here crying while you call me a degenerate.
But hey, at least we're all the same, like, brand of
degenerate.
Yeah.
I
think that's why we're a great group.
We're just a mishmash of craziness.
Honestly, this is true Dampa.
We can be serious when we need to be serious and then when
we want to say stupid stuff we say the most stupid stuff
that's what i love about us you know yeah agreed yeah i love
you guys so much oh apparently liz is in chat thanks liz we
love we love you too yeah you're amazing thanks for dropping
by!
Thank you so much for popping in.
Actually, Liz being here and then talking about our
impressions of each other over the years has reminded me
that there are so many... There are a lot of us who have
come a very, very, very long way together.
Like, who...
Like, we've been looking at each other and admiring each
other for a very, very, very long time.
And now here we are, somehow ending up in the same place,
the same weird VTuber space together it's a really beautiful
thing the world is so big but we still managed to find each
other he did oh i think it would have happened in any
universe even if we were i don't know little palace cats in
mongolia yeah congregated together i would find you guys as
a palace cat as well as a worm as as a worm You love the
Palace of Worm.
Worm.exe.
Yeah, I think so.
Aww, you guys.
It would be forever!
Forever!
Yeah.
This was a good question.
Thank you, Denchi.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, man, I need to...
I need to blow my nose real fast.
Give me a kiss.
Yeah, I'm gonna take some water as well, yeah.
Goop, goop, goop.
I'll take a sip too.
Yeah.
I am out of water, actually.
But, oh, let me fill it.
Actually, can I BRB then?
Can I go get some water?
Yeah, go get it.
Yeah, do it.
Hey, chat.
Hey, Chai.
Hi.
Are you there?
What?
Hey there.
Oh, hi there.
MVP forever.
Yeah.
Aw.
Trying to think.
I feel like there's like, you know, sometimes I'm like,
does, you know, do people see me as a degenerate?
I feel like the moment recently where I was like, wow, I've
really outed myself.
You know when we were in the queue at Disney?
And I was like saying that Shmi's mom was hauled or
something.
I remember.
There was like a portrait of Shmi's mom.
on the wall.
I feel like that was a moment where I was like, wow, I'm
glad I could be my true self.
It's coming out.
That's not, sorry.
No, never apologize for being you.
Yeah, I'm just, this is so nice to know I can just be me.
The best part, everybody is Sme from Peter Pan.
The Sme's mom looks exactly like Sme.
But with a wig on.
what even smee's mom wasn't just smee with a wig i don't
know we were like is that smee with a wig on
wait were we talking about mr smee's mom all i heard was
smee yeah sorry i was just saying i'm so happy i can be
myself with you guys you know i can just say what's ever on
my mind judged you know no you know how did we go on mr
smee's bomb how did we she's got it going on she's got it
going i wonder if we took a picture of it i don't know
waited for so long so long anyway anyway move on to the next
question maybe yeah might be a good idea i almost spit my
water Here next question Yippee Yippee Woohoo Oh gosh Group
question Group question Next one is
Were there any Oh Were there any other names you considered
before going with Den Setsu.exe, there kind of were, right?
There were, actually.
Yeah, there were.
I don't know if we have the doc.
We could try and find the document.
We have the doc.
The document somewhere.
Somewhere.
In the depths where we tried to find it.
Yeah, oh, yeah, maybe.
Hmm.
Hmm, I'm gonna go scour.
We did vote.
Yeah.
I think so.
Oh, looking for the old.
Let me find, like, the oldest possible document.
I know, right?
The Shoujo server.
Oh, yo.
It is.
It's dusty in there.
Be careful.
It's so dusty.
I'm going to search name.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I have.
I found brainstorms for what our fan names were going to be.
At the very least.
Oh, fan names.
Oh, that's fine.
A cultist.
Mythbusters, Bookworms, Protagonists, Mythbits, Misfits, or
Hackers, or...
Oh yeah, Denpotachi was another one, but we ended up going
with Denhi.
It's funny because I feel like one of those fits this
upcoming song, and then one of the other names fits another
project that we're working on.
That's so true!
Way!
That's kind of funny.
Whoa!
It's crazy!
Yeah.
Oshikats!
Yeah, come on.
Oshikats was another one!
Oshikats!
I remember liking Oshikats.
I can only remember.
I can remember for the names, like, we were thinking of MVP
as a name at one point, weren't we?
I think so.
We just got sent one of them.
Hold on.
Akiba MVP.
We had a Densetsu.exe.
We had Electric Girls.
Electric Girls.
What a star in the community.
We had Moe Rangers.
Wise Heart.
Oh, we have Wise Heart.
It's like Y apostrophe S.
And then Heart.
Yeah, like Muse.
Akiba MVP.
Yeah, that was the first possible.
I mean, in the end, we ended up using MVP anyway.
So Natsukashi.
Wow, that is super Natsukashi.
I should have gotten about Electric Girls.
So what do you think, guys?
You glad it's DenSetsu.exe?
Yeah, do you like it?
I think MVPs would have worked just as well, but I think
DenSetsu.exu sounds a little cooler.
I agree.
I think maybe if the Akiba MVP were like stylized a little
more or something.
Instead of just the...
Yeah, whatever that is right there.
Yeah.
But we're still MVP regardless.
I think it's nice that we can bring out MVP for like, I
don't know, lyrics and stuff.
But we can...
We have it in set to Aixir's the name, you know?
Because it describes all of us with our Yureyusei Yokai
thing going on.
I've got to not do the thing.
Okay.
Fucking Vicky, we have Daddy Brass E-X-E
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes.
Um, so, wow, thanks so much Tinfoil for having that somehow.
Yeah, how?
How did it happen?
Where did he get that?
Where is this from?
Oh my god, thank you.
Where did he get that?
I don't know where he got it.
Where did he get it from?
Of all people?
Yeah, that's not true.
What's that gonna be?
Where's...
Tinfoil works in mysterious ways.
But he also is a very essential part of keeping the
operation going.
So you guys might not see him in the front like Steiner.
But Tinfoil and Dovec.
And then some of our other staff members are always, always
working really hard to keep it going.
So thanks you guys.
Tinfoil, I'll get my message to you.
For the Patreon.
Oh yeah!
Can I say real quick that one of the first times I met
Tinfoil was he was hired on as a bartender for my housemates
Off-Kai party.
And that was before all of this Den Setsu, or before we had
reconvened as the Den Setsu that we are today.
But like, I didn't think that the guy that was bartending at
the party would end up becoming like, Technically, like,
he's not really our boss, but, like...
One of our co-workers.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
So he bartends, too.
Yeah.
He's so multi-talented.
So cool.
You're his boss.
You're right.
We are, in fact, we are kind of, we are the bosses,
actually.
Yeah, we're the bosses.
It's never gonna do the solo questions ever.
No.
But the group questions are fun anyway.
Group question!
What do you plan on doing with Akiba once you take it?
Good question.
Oh.
I'll feed it and nurse it and make sure...
It grows up big and strong.
Happy and warm.
Yeah.
We should make every day Sunday.
You know, people can walk through, you know?
True pedestrian heaven every day.
Yeah.
Every day.
I'm gonna gas up my favorite bunny cafe, Anacuba.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Mothrel.
And then it's gonna be the, that's gonna become the town
hall.
you must go see the bunnies
we haven't thought that far about our world domination plans
yeah we're gonna take it and you'll like it yeah we're gonna
take it and we're gonna do something with it yeah yeah yeah
it's secret we can't go telling you guys our top secret
plans also it's It's not bunny girls, they're literal
rabbits.
They're literal rabbits.
They're like, ooh, sexy bunny girl town hall.
I'm like, no, they're just actual rabbits.
What?
What's going on?
Actually, the first maid cafe I went to in Niki Hopper was
like a bunny outfit maid cafe.
Oh.
I went with my dad.
You guys?
A certain mysterious waiting room has been...
Oh, a mysterious waiting room.
Let me go make sure that that redirect is set up properly.
Yeah, yeah.
A certain mysterious word.
Wow.
It's very mysterious.
Why is it bot?
Why is our name in question marks?
Yeah, what?
Dude, our name doesn't have to be in question marks, you
dang did.
Just to give them more to be mysterious about it, I guess.
Who could it be?
I wonder.
Ooh!
Mmm, mysterious way to run, guys!
I wonder who that is!
Is there a tweet that I can retweet for it right now?
Uh, let me see.
I wonder.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna pin...
I'm gonna pin this now.
If that's okay with you guys.
No tweet yet.
Okay.
Line up for Premiere here.
Actually, no, do you guys think that I should pin this or
should I just keep the current pin?
Oh, I think it's okay to do the...
Yeah.
Oh, I just heard tweet is going up.
I'm refreshing.
There, new pinned message in the chat.
Ooh, in 28 minutes.
Whoa!
Wait, I'm so excited.
Right, right.
I'm refreshing.
Sorry, guys.
I'm just doing something.
I'll be right back in the...
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
As you guys can see, we're very, very excited for this.
You Hakuo-oshi, question mark, question mark, question mark,
dot, question mark, question mark, question mark.
Damn, you don't even know who's in that group yet.
Are you guys getting new members?
Who are those girls in the thumbnail?
I wonder.
Who could those be?
I don't recognize the shapes at all.
No, I've never seen that before in my entire...
afterlife.
Oh my gosh, Dare.
Who could this be?
Um, I don't think this is revealing too much if I say we
have one more person to confirm for the earlier time of
certain calling.
So I'm just waiting.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay, so we will know soon if we're going to have one just
one more person to confirm and then it'll be okay.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
So give me a second.
waiting
yeah well guys again excited for the mystery very mysterious
oh oh so miss so exciting so excited what do you guys think
of the visual i it's much silhouetted but um chat what what
what are you thinking oh yeah what are the what are what are
your impressions what are the vibes
It's explosive.
It's fiery.
I dare say it's hot blooded.
Are we just saying it now?
Phoebe
Leaks, Phoebe Leaks.
Phoebe Leaks!
I say nothing.
They don't know.
You don't know.
You guys don't know.
They have no idea.
I'm seeing some key words of things that we...
That kind of match the vibe, so...
Yeah.
I think...
You know, they're figuring it out on their own.
We're not...
We're not saying...
Anything.
Your girls need to hire a plumber at this point.
Oh, he went back to the sink.
I see someone in the...
In the premiere waiting room saying, There appears to be an
explosion.
Seems promising.
Oh.
You guys, you guys like explosions?
I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I think I'm gonna explode.
I'm gonna explode.
I need a mute.
You guys don't even know.
You don't, you don't even know.
Oh my god.
Explosive, huh?
Are you
okay?
I'm not okay.
Oh, sorry.
Did you hear me banging on my desk?
Guys, should we...
do we've got we've still got 10 minutes should we do another
question to stop ourselves yes yes please yes please yes
what if it's finally a solo one that would be really funny
me you gotta eat a durian or something it's gonna be
something like i'm telling you okay what's the question oh
god why should we just do another group one group one but
here's your question is so funny though why did the super
cross the road to be free on the other side ah
can we get another question please can we can we get another
okay this has to say group great like group question let's
just go group question okay great it's funny because it was
a question but they answered it themselves so yeah exactly
not a real question
Oh my god.
Uh, this...
Okay, I was like, what number are we on this one?
Ta-da!
Congrats on achieving so much in the past six months!
What would you like to each accomplish with Densetsu in the
next six months?
Can be realistic or delusional.
Who wants to go first?
Well, we already know a few things.
Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah, that's the thing.
I feel like a lot of our stuff we've already planned out we
can't tell anyone that's the problem so here's the thing you
guys we know what we're gonna accomplish in the next six
months that's why it's like you mean even I think it would
have been better to be like oh the next like year or
something like that but uh hmm wait would you like to would
you want me to just choose another question maybe more yeah
I feel like we we did a question to stop us leaking and then
we're just gonna leak guys we're bad we're bad at this uh
thank you for making Steiner's life difficult there is no
question here insert Ibu Lapui's gift here I think this
person might um enjoy the video
chat I have a question for you who here show of hands enjoys
Steiner suffering show of hands show of hands don't be shy
don't be shy who wants to see him literally explode who
wants to who wants to see him like like what if we told you
that this entire project is revolves around steiner's
suffering it's
just too dangerous too dangerous i'm sorry oh Can we just
move the premiere to now?
Yeah, no, right?
Okay, new question.
New question.
How does everything come back to the video?
Here.
If you could impart one piece of wisdom onto an aging
ex-introvert that wants to break out and go to VTuber cons
and concerts, what would it be?
Anything to avoid, something to try, or should you bring,
etc.
You can assume hygiene slash clean attire is well accounted
for.
Oh, so we can't say wear deodorant.
Or shower.
Um, Who wants to go first?
Can I go?
I can make conventions.
There are so many...
Meetups.
You know, if you're in a Discord for like, you know, a
VTuber that you like, you can always see if anybody's going
to that event and doing a meetup.
And then that's just an easy...
You already have something to talk about because you all
like the same thing already.
So that's my advice.
Hmm.
I think that's very important to keep in mind, right?
Is that, like, if you're at this event, already you have at
least one thing in common with the people around you.
Chances are, like, they're there because they love...
Most of the people there are there because they love a lot
of the same things you love and a lot of the same ways that
you love them.
So I think...
I've seen a lot of people, like, ask questions about, like,
oh, like, I'm worried about other people judging me.
And I'm like, well, if you think about it, you're just kind
of all there for the same purpose anyway.
So you already have something, you guaranteed, when you walk
around in the day to day, you don't know if you have
anything in common with the person next to you on the bus,
but you know here that you have something in common with
every single person around you.
So just take a, yeah, don't think about, because if you're
not judging them, they're probably not judging you either.
You know, they're just here to have fun.
Go for it.
What about you, Vicky?
I truly do, oh, go ahead, sorry.
No, I was just saying, what about you, Vicky?
I truly, like, I know a lot of people hate this phrase, I
truly do believe in YOLO, like, you could only do this kind
of stuff, this one time, this one life, so if you love
something, just show that you love it wholeheartedly, wear
it on your sleeve, and there'll be plenty of other people
that love the same thing as you and want to spend their life
loving the same thing, and, you know, I know it can be a bit
scary, especially, like, I don't know if you had because
you're an introvert, maybe you find it slightly harder to
talk to people or something.
But there will be other people, as they say, like other
people like you, you know, that feel the same way.
And I think being able to talk to those like-minded people
and just, yeah, without shame, just show the things that you
love is one of the most powerful things you can do in life.
And I think once you can let go of the kind of like
expectations of people or, oh, will people think this?
will people think that and just saying no i want to do this
because i love this thing i think that's one of the moments
you feel genuinely free would be what i would say yeah and
it's that kind of freedom is so such a good feeling one
other thing one other thing too is if you're also you know
you're the introvert you're like okay well i went to the
event but i'm too nervous to go up to people one thing you
could do is you can wear you know a t-shirt of your favorite
vtuber or you and then other people can see that, oh, they
like this person, and then they could come up to you.
They'll come up to you, they will.
Yeah, so then, you know, it's much easier to connect, so be,
you know, some people are like, oh, anime shirts are cringe,
but be cringe and free.
Yes.
Actually, that kind of reminds me of the thing we're going
to premiere.
It is!
Well, I think it's not bad.
to talk about a little bit of the messaging just being like
being able to be yourself right yeah yeah yeah yeah be
yourself and be there for the people that are also like that
also love the things that you love and that also are just
trying to be themselves I think Vicky's right like life is
way too short not to do the things you love or love the
things you love so just love it so true yeah and there's
always people who are gonna be behind you and supporting you
so yeah yeah people are probably like, what does that have
to do with Steiner's suffering?
And I really...
No!
It's good messaging, you guys.
We promise.
We worked really hard on these lyrics, actually, so...
Yeah.
It'd be really nice at some point to do, like, a deep dive
into our lyric writing or something.
I'd love to know that thing sometimes.
Yeah.
Oh, I'd love that.
But not today.
That was spoiled, but...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We worked really, really hard on these.
We're always, we're always...
We kind of have like a...
Like an assembly line kind of process that we've gotten
into.
Yeah, we have actually.
Yeah, we each have our own strengths and stuff.
I was literally talking to you about this like a month ago,
Vicky, right?
Like how each of us is really good at different things when
it comes to our lyric writing.
I feel like we're all very good at everything, but like in
particular, really good at like one-liners that are like wow
that is a sick line that's that's yeah the aura farming i
think i'm quite good at like concepts and then i think feby
is like super good at like bringing it all together and like
making it pretty and being like wham here's the final thing
you know yeah mickey i've never done lyrics writing before
so i'm i was really intimidated but you guys have made it so
you guys have taken my dumb one-liners and been like yeah
this is great and so good you guys one of my favorite things
is like taking the the the best parts of your guys's ideas
and then making it into like a one long cohesive singable
thing is like really really fun because i'm like oh that was
the that was that thing from mid and there was that thing
from vicky yeah and then how can we make it like all come
together yeah whoa i think i definitely did that like oh
sorry go ahead no no we're like each different chefs in the
kitchen you guys bring me some really good ingredients as
well.
And some great ideas.
I think with this song too, it kind of ended up where I had
written a chunk and then Vicky had written a chunk and
Phoebe had written a chunk.
So kind of it really just like meshed all together.
And then, you know, Phoebe also helped bring it all, tie it
all together too.
So it was, yeah, it works so well.
I'm so happy to have that kind of experience with you guys.
Being able to write together with you is just like, oh, it's
so nice.
I appreciate it so much.
By the way, it's time.
Oh, it is time.
We might want to go to Be Right Backscreen, so I feel like
it's going to take you a little while, right?
Yeah, it's going to take a little bit of some time to set
all of your thoughts on.
Okay, so we're going to be right back again.
See you guys in a second.
With guests.
Yes.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you.
Hello.
Let's see.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes,
please.
Hello, hello.
Hi, I'm HOTAL.
YORSHICU.
YORSHICU, please.
Yay!
Yay, yay.
Hi, everyone, Ko-happiness.
My name is Ko-happiness.
Hi, everyone.
It's your new dream, big, shine, bright, Hestia, happiness.
Hello, I'm an angel YouTuber.
Nice to meet you.
Hi.
Hestia!
Tensai, Tutsu Damegami-sama, Yizuri, Peke-de-yo!
Yurishiko-ne-gai-yes.
Thank you, thank you.
Peke-te-chai-yai!
Yay!
Hi, everyone.
Konnagi!
I'm also the world's user, game, or I'm Aisha, or Game, or
I'm Aisha, or I'm Aisha.
I'm Nagi, Okamoto!
Yoramasu, nice to meet you!
Nice to meet you!
Today we are joined by Nova, and they're all super duper
cute.
I'm so happy!
Yata!
I'm really happy!
Thank you!
Yeah, I'm so happy.
The said, you know, today is a six-month That's a good idea.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah,
thank you.
Thank you.
Happy six months anniversary.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Wow.
Yeah, like, collaboration, like, Yeah, that's right.
I want to.
Thank you.
I'm always going to be supporting you.
Yeah, we're going to be supporting you.
Oh, yeah.
I've heard three of them heard them, but they're so, so
cute.
Yeah.
I really like your songs.
um kawaii yeah kawaii kawaii kawaii yeah I'm not
kawaii, um kei language is I can't speak English, I can't
speak English I can't speak English
Thank you.
Yeah.
But how many...
How many...
then, go to Mint.
Mint, Phoebe.
Oh, uh...
Uh...
Um...
I don't remember.
I don't know.
Well, I did.
But, honestly, I forgot to say that.
I forgot to say that.
That's so cute.
Uh, uh, uh, I also gotta do it.
Yeah, it's great.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Japanese.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Show English to a level is different.
Wait, I said Mint-chan's voice is not even heard, so I said
zero in here.
What?
I said that, I mean, Mint-chan was even here, I didn't hear
it.
That's a very weird conversation.
Oh, yes, I was also- It's a very weird conversation.
Hey, Mint-chan's voice is finally heard!
Yeah, yeah, that was the video.
Don't worry.
I'm sorry.
I'm talking.
Oh, my God.
So, is that?
So, last time I collabed, I think he was speaking in
English, so...
Mostly, I think so.
Yeah.
Your English is so, so, so good as well.
Oh, so, like, my English is my first language.
Oh, the first!
Oh, okay, so I learned Japanese, and I'm streaming in
Japanese.
Oh, it's amazing, though.
Wow!
Oh, thank you.
Well, I want to get better Japanese, too, because...
I want to know more about you, but I want to understand
myself about myself.
Hey, I know it's okay.
No problem.
No, I'm happy.
Let's play.
You know, you're like me.
Uh, uh, uh!
Very cute.
Yeah, I'm so happy.
I'm so happy.
I'm a little bit different, but well, it's been 10 years
over, I think.
Oh, my God.
That's why I'm so happy.
Can you teach me?
What is that?
Ricky, Riki, Riki, Riki, Riki.
Riki, Riki, Riki, Please let me know.
I can't even speak.
No.
But I really want to collaborate with Nova sometime.
We want to hang out and talk with them more despite any
language barriers.
always, we're always always cheering them on.
And so I hope you guys will support them too.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Subscribe to all of them.
Subscribe to yo.
Thank you!
Thank you so much for today!
Thanks for coming!
Thank you so much for inviting us!
Thank you!
I'll talk to you guys soon!
Bye-bye!
Congratulations!
Yay!
So, uh, unfortunately, we've got a start rapping super duper
fast here unfortunately I hope you guys are super duper fast
oh my god I'm gonna cry first for anything guys I have one
more question for you yeah how do you feel about loitering
chat how do you feel about loitering how do you feel how do
you feel anybody who loiteres deserves to be exploded
exploded right I agree!
I agree!
Well, Dewa Dewa, shall we go see what happens to people that
loiter?
Yeah!
Let's go Raiden!
Give, share this with all your family and friends and give
it lots and lots of
love!
We should say, we should say the title here.
Let's say the title together.
Oh, yes!
Please enjoy our second single...
Burn on!